This is a critical issue with regards to
the shamanic transformation is that
people go through these terrible,
terrible experiences,
often drug induced by the way,
with regards to the [inaudible].
They usually use psychedelic chemicals
of one form or another,
often mushrooms,
but they've come up with some very
strange concoctions like Iowasca down in
the Amazon and Iowasca has an amazing
substance.
It's made out of the bark of one thing
and another plant whose name I don't
remember that hardly even grow in the
same place and that has to be cooked
together in a special way and no one has
any idea how the damn Amazonians figured
that out.
It looks impossible and if you ask them,
they say,
well,
the plants told us how to do it,
which was western people don't find very
helpful,
but the shamans are perfectly healthy,
happy with that description and Iowasca
takes them apart and it does that in
part because it effects the serotonergic
system very,
very powerfully.
Like all psychedelics do and it
transports them to another world and
that's how they interpreted.
And,
and,
and what we know about psychedelics.
You can put in a thimble and then throw
the thimble away.
We know nothing about psychedelics,
so there's new experiments going on at
Johns Hopkins,
for example,
with suicide,
but in which is part of this active
chemical in magic mushrooms,
same structure basically as Lsd and
masculine and all the real psychedelics
have basically the same structure except
the one that's derived from Anita
Mascara,
which is called muscular kinic acid and
it's a.
it's its own weird thing that no one
knows anything about.
Anyways,
they have profound neurochemical effects
in very small doses and I'm the research
group at Johns Hopkins has given
psilocybin to research subjects,
purified psilocybin because they started
the new experimentation with
psychedelics and that's been banned for
like 40 years because psychedelics were
so terrifying to our culture that we
just put them away and it's like,
oh no,
we're not going there.
And so even from a research perspective,
and even though some of the psychedelics
look very promising for the treatment of
disorders like alcoholism,
they recently used psilocybin to help
people stop smoking down at Johns
Hopkins and I think they had an 80
percent success rate.
Which is just like,
that's just absolutely mind boggling and
so,
but if you give people silicide and they
have a mystical experience,
which is very common among people who
take these sorts of chemicals,
then their personality transforms
permanently such that one year later
they're one standard deviation,
higher in openness and openness is the
creativity dimension and that seems to
be a permanent transformation and so
that's really remarkable.
And about 80 percent of the people who
undergo the Johns Hopkins Experiments
report that the experience is like one
of the two or three most important
things they've ever.
That's never ever happened to them.
And so.
Well that's,
that's something,
you know,
it's like.
And then there's this guy named Rick
strassman down at,
I think it was at the University of
Texas and he did experimentation with
DMT,
die,
Mathilde tryptamine I remember if I
remember correctly,
is the active ingredient in Iowasca and
you produce it in your brain and it's in
plants.
It's like a very common chemical,
but DMT is a weird hallucinogen because
it has an extraordinary short mechanism
of action.
It's like,
and people who take it report that
they're blasted out of their body,
like out of a cannon,
and then they go out somewhere and
encounter beings of various sorts and
then 10 minutes later they're back and
virtually everyone reports that,
which is really strange.
And,
and so straussman was giving people dmt
intravenously so that the trip would
last longer.
He,
this was all,
all nih funded,
uh,
experimentation all cleared with the
relevant ethics boards all conducted
within the last 10 years.
And he basically quit doing it because
he was a pretty straight scientists,
you know,
he was measuring heart rate and pulse
and all that sort of thing,
trying to look at the physiology and
then the people he was giving these
chemicals to kept coming back and
telling them these,
these crazy stories.
And uh,
well it just,
it was too much for them,
you know,
and no wonder,
because they all said the same thing.
And he'd say,
well,
that was a dream.
And they'd say no.
And it was the most real thing that ever
happened to me.
And he'd say,
well,
you know,
it's an archetypal experience.
And they'd say,
no,
that was no archetypal experience.
I went somewhere else and I saw things
and I'm back and I don't care what you
think and like,
who the hell knows?
Right?
Because it's all subjective.
But,
but the weird thing about it is that
everyone's reporting the same thing.
How the hell do you account for that?
And then the shaman,
you know,
when they take these psychedelic
chemicals,
they basically say the same thing.
They say,
well first of all,
it more or less killed me.
That's this.
No,
I dissolved to the skeleton.
And then I climbed a tree that Unites
Heaven and earth and I went into the
realm of the gods and they gave me some
information and I'm back.
It's like,
okay,
well,
you know,
we don't really know what to make of
that.
And we certainly.
That's what len describes when he
describes the shamonic,
this romantic procession,
not the shamanic initiation.
And you know,
there's dissolution to a skeleton first
and then like a death,
this symbolic death or experienced as an
actual death.
And then bang up into the realm of the
gods and then they come back.
It's a very old idea and that's a
medieval representation of the tunnel
that people travel through at the end of
their life to,
you know,
to find the light,
which is a very common near death
experience report.
And people don't have any idea what the
hell to do with those reports except
say,
well,
it's the paroxysms of the dying brain,
which you'd expect to be a hell of a lot
more random in my opinion.
And the idea is there's a rebirth after
that and you know,
here this is the Scandinavian
representation of that tree that unites
Earth with heaven.
And so there's this Scandinavian
representation,
has a snake snakes down here eating it.
And then that's the Amazonian
representation.
It's like,
how the hell do you account for that?
I mean,
those,
those pictures are so similar that it's
just,
it's beyond belief.
Well,
you know,
we lived in trees for a long time,
a long,
long,
long time,
millions of years,
and there were lots of snakes around
them.
And so the idea that reality is that
tree that's surrounded by a snake is,
that's in house,
man.
It's down there,
it's deep.
And there's something about it that's
true,
not true.
Like we normally think of truth,
a truth true in an entirely different
manner.
So,
and all that's pretty damn strange.
We'll start with this.
My son drew this when he was seven years
old.
Blew me away man.
I thought it was so cool.
So I had it laminated.
And so here is what it is on the right
hand side,
that's the order.
It's like the Yin Yang thing that's
ordered left side chaos,
right?
And those are all mushroom houses,
which I thought was amazing.
And then there's this river that runs
right down the middle,
like the line for order and chaos.
And then there's this tree that goes up
to heaven and that's having up there.
It's like there is St Peter,
there's the pearly gates,
there's the cloud.
It's like he never went to church,
you know,
it's like what the hell?
And then there's a little bug there that
goes up and down from heaven to earth.
And that was him,
I thought he had a very organized
psyche,
that kid,
he was a very,
very stable kid and still is and know he
drew that.
And I thought,
Jesus,
that's just bloody well,
unbelievable.
And I still think that when I look at
it,
and that's a great example of an
archetype.
And so we'll see you Tuesday.